And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
You don't have a lot of questions that were submitted today,
so hopefully you guys have questions.
I'm going to be a short Zoom call.
All right, let's get started.
All right.
Just a reminder to everybody to look at the.
Remember site for any new information, anything new coming on board.
Also reminder to make sure you look at the courses.
A lot of benefit to the courses and to new blog posts as well.
Got a couple of new people on today.
You can use the chat on your Zoom to chat in questions.
So just chat in a question.
If you have a question that you couldn't ask prior to the Zoom call.
Remember also to self schedule.
If you need to do so, you need to talk to me specific.
Lee, when you get to this self schedule thing and you click on it,
you will be given a choice whether you want to just schedule a regular phone call.
Or if you schedule a Zoom call.
And the only time you really want to schedule a Zoom call is if you're setting me labs.
And you want to go over or that we got labs back that we want to go over.
Doing a Zoom call could be helpful because then I can share my screen.
And you'll see my pointer as I'm talking about this thing right here.
You know, you'll be able to see what I'm talking about.
So I don't have to say see on page one up or left hand quarter blah blah blah.
So doing a Zoom call to go over labs can be helpful.
All right, let's get started.
Curious about glutathione should most breast cancer patients include this with their supplement regimen.
Um, I would say no.
So the pros and cons of glutathione.
So glutathione is your main your primary intra cellular inside the cell antioxidant.
So, um, you have processes of oxidation and antioxidation going on in your body.
Extracellally meeting outside the cell and intracellally inside the cell.
So the glutathione is your main intra cellular antioxidant.
It's made in the cell.
And, um, and you and it's, um, and it breaks down oxidizing agents that enter into the cell.
Now, whatever you listen and read about oxidizing agents, you think of them as.
Poisons or bad guys things that oxidized cells can cause cancer.
So that's true. So any poison or a toxin is an oxidizing agent.
And it is, um, it's cancer causing it can damage cell membranes.
It can damage the nucleus of the cell.
And if it damages the nucleus of the cell, it can be a cause for cancer.
Um, by oxidizing the amino acids in the, in the, um, DNA, it can damage the DNA.
So oxidizing agents can be damaging.
However, there's a balance to that.
Everything in physiology has a balance.
Your body actually makes reactive oxygen species for the purpose of killing biotoxins.
So when you have a biotoxin, let's say you have, you know, a bacteria or a virus, your body will make reactive oxygen species to kill that virus or kill that bacteria.
So it's all about balance. So remember that.
So I know we live in a world where you read a lot about antioxidants.
And you should be taking a lot of antioxidants.
Well, there may be truth to that.
I've seen a lot of antioxidants can be helpful because we're exposed to so many oxidizing agents and pesticides, chemicals, heavy metals, toxins, Michael toxins, all these things are oxidizing agents.
So trying to balance out the amount of oxidizing agents that are damaging our cell or have a potential causing cancer with taking some extra antioxidants can be helpful.
However, if you're trying to kill cancer, you have to keep that balance that you're not using too many oxidizing agents because sometimes your body uses reactive oxygen species to kill cancer cells.
That's exactly how chemotherapy works.
Therapy is an oxidizing agent and cancer cells to be tend to be more prone to damage to oxidizing agents that a healthy cell does be partly because a healthy cell is healthy because the components of the cell are doing their job.
And glutathione is a component that's recycled within the cell.
So you don't actually need any exogenous glutathione, a healthy person not exposed to excess oxidizing agents does not need to take glutathione as a supplement.
Because glutathione is recycled inside the cell, it's oxidized and reduced through a process of recycling inside the cell.
So yeah, it does need, you know, the nutrients in order to do that.
And so, you know, taking some nutrients that can help that but typically an average person would get that either diet as well.
So, why would a person take glutathione?
It's all because they're realizing that they're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents so they want to support the glutathione pathway.
Why wouldn't a person take glutathione?
If you're doing keyboard therapy, if you're doing another oxidizing agent, like there's different supplements that are that kill cancer through the process of oxidization,
protocell is one of those things so you don't take glutathione when you're taking protocell.
And, you know, you got to keep that balance.
I only tell cancer patients to take glutathione if it tests on the cheek swab that it's okay for them to take it.
If you're reading my book, I'm not so positive on glutathione with cancer because you are, you know, cancer.
Cancer cells are more prone to die through oxidation.
And if you are, you could actually be keeping cancer cells alive by taking glutathione.
So, I only tell people, I only recommend glutathione with people that it tests well with otherwise I don't suggest glutathione.
And I don't suggest excess antioxidants with cancer patients unless it tests well.
So, lots of times in the natural world, if you go to a natural path or a chiropractor or some natural doctor who's who's reading literature about, you know, other health conditions.
And then you have been a patient there and now you get, you know, you're going to diagnose the cancer and that person is helping you, but they don't really have a specialty in cancer.
They may put you on high dose antioxidants and that might not be the right thing to do.
So, there's some things that you would normally that could be helpful for you from a nutritional standpoint.
If you don't have cancer and those same things might not be the right thing to take if a person does have cancer.
So, it's a very long 10 minute answer to the question should most breast cancer patients include this with their supplement regimen?
The answer is no.
And the reason is that you may be keeping cancer cells alive by taking glutathione.
Or you may be counteracted in oxidative therapy that you're doing either chemotherapy or some nutritional in oxidative therapy.
So, the answer to this short answer is just no.
Lately, I thought I was taking too many supplements.
So, I decided to take the astro clear, aerobic clear, and so four is on three times a day every day.
And by osteopaths and other osteopaths recommendations and other vitamins every other day.
Do you see any downside for this?
So, this person, I know the person who asked this question and they are doing fantastic with their cancer.
You could say they're in complete revision.
So, I am all together and favor doing this. This would be called Paul Seed.
So, Paul Seed, your supplements is that you're taking some time off.
You can take them five days a week and off on the weekends or you can do it every other day.
Just like this, I think that would be fine, especially if you're in a good position health-wise to do some Paul Seed.
Are there any vitamins you would recommend that must be taken daily instead of every other day?
I think you're making the right decision.
I think we talked about this on a call.
These are things that you're taking to reduce bad astrogens.
So, there would be something that you do want to take on a daily basis.
Other things you could take, you could separate out.
But I think you might want to take on a daily basis or in the summertime if you're sweating a lot, you might want to stay on minerals.
Things that you could pulse very easily would be your fat-soluble vitamins, your A and E and D and K.
Those are things that store well in your body.
Water-soluble, nutritional, things tend to not store well.
Things that maybe you'd want to take on a daily basis, maybe you might make a decision based upon cold morbidities.
Let's say you have inflammation so you want to stay on anti-inflammatories, the flavonoids on a daily basis.
Then I wouldn't suggest pulsing and doing this on somebody that's, you know, is not going to clean bill of health and doing great.
So, stay to your protocol at that point.
Recently had good results with latest MRI.
Appears resection margins are clean, no, and tumor reduced in size from 10 centimeters to 1.8 centimeters.
This person had surgical resection.
Plus, suspect lymph nodes are now are not visible on latest CT skin, admittable on the MRI.
Getting another MRI next week for additional detail based on radiologist recommendation.
It appears that the oncologist still recommends 4 to 6 sessions of port-based full-fox or just 5FU.
I understand this is to weaken cancer cells and to prevent distant metastasis.
Yet this is also something that's going to weaken the immune system and does not kill cancer stem cells.
When I ask they say, it's all about the immune system.
It's not all about the immune system.
Thoughts on general on the chemo process.
I just don't want to take unnecessary risk, not sure what strategy is more risky, either.
Okay, so my thoughts on doing chemo.
If you had a default in procedure where the cancer was encapsulated and they're able to basically get the entire capsule.
No eat full well if there's probably circulated tumor cells elsewhere.
That would not be a reason to do chemo.
Like if you have circulated tumor cells, there's no cancer.
Your pet scan is completely clean.
Should a person do chemo at that point?
Yeah, that's real questionable.
This case, you know that there's still some cancer that's present.
It's smaller.
You know, it's still there's still some there.
I would be more apt to say, okay, I've gone this far to do the resection resection.
You know, I would be maybe willing to start to do the chemo process and see how you do.
Remember, some people petty genetically on their detoxification pathways and the health of their liver.
They could just sail right through this and you know, they haven't been those are the people that have fantastic results with the chemo.
And it did its job because you were able to get it out of the body before it was able to damage any healthy cells.
How are you going to know that?
Well, the only way that you're going to know that you know that is to do one session at a time.
So, you know, of course, I would pray about it.
Of course, I would, you know, give as much consideration as possible, but I wouldn't, you know, completely rule it out.
So, my opinion, you're getting multiple people's opinion, my opinion, I wouldn't rule it out.
This could, you know, really put an end to the, your, your struggle that you had up to this point by doing maybe only a couple of sessions.
Maybe, maybe, maybe make a deal with the oncologist say, hey, I'll be willing to agree session at a time here.
How I, how I do with it. If I do well with the first session, I'll move on to the second session.
If you'll be willing to take another scan after three sessions, something like that. I mean, that seems reasonable.
Because honestly, if you said, well, why are you recommending four to six sessions.
He's going to say, well, that's the bottom line is because that's what is recommended by the pharmaceutical company.
They might say, well, that's what we've done and we've had great results.
If you, if you pushed that and said, have you ever done three sessions, I mean, they wouldn't have an answer.
So, the truth is, is that, you know, 90% of the people just do what they tell them to do.
So, they don't test. There is no test whether only one session is good or two sessions are good or who's who came up with the four to six sessions.
The pharmaceutical company. So, there's nothing wrong with giving some pushback.
You know, hey, I'm willing to use my brain here that yeah, some chemo could really knock down what's left.
But, you know, I'm the one that's in control of my body and I'll decide when I want to stop.
But I would like objective testing. Are you willing to do another MRI or CT scan? That's what I would say.
What are your thoughts on nicotine and its effect on cancer?
Regarding cancer in inferences. Can I go to a local tanning facility that offers inferences or do I need to go elsewhere?
What is appreciated? So, this one, yeah, you can go to a local tanning facility that offers inferences on us. That's just fine.
I don't see any problem with that. You know, there's not toxins or anything that you're going to pick up at a local tanning facility doing a sauna.
So, I don't see any issue with that. This I think is a completely separate question nicotine and its effect on cancer.
Well, at first glance, I mean nicotine, you know, is a major cause of lung cancer and that's still the number.
I think it's the number one deadly cancer is a small cell lung cancer.
But in truth, it's more probably the chemicals that they put in tobacco and not necessarily the nicotine.
I mean, they put addictive forming chemicals in tobacco.
So, tobacco today is very different than tobacco, maybe back in the 1800s.
So, tobacco is screened with the addiction forming chemicals in order to get people to be addicted to it to continue to buy their tobacco.
That is probably the most carcinogen aspect of tobacco.
So, but in truth, nicotine is still probably should be considered a toxic substance.
I don't think it should be consumed.
People will say, well, tobacco is just a natural substance. I mean, it's God made it.
I don't think we're supposed to smoke it just because God made it doesn't mean we're supposed to smoke it just because God made rocks doesn't mean we're supposed to eat them.
So, you can't use that excuse with something that's consumed.
So, you know, I don't know if your question really has to do with second-hand smoke.
And it's affected our sarcoma. I don't know if any studies are that.
I would definitely say that nicotine is a toxin. It isn't good for anybody.
So, but if it's, you're dealing with second-hand smoke, you're dealing with a lot more toxins than just a nicotine.
That's in that smoke. So, it's highly toxic substance.
Okay, questions from the chat. We are needing to replace carpet in our house.
I've heard there could be some toxic outgassing with new carpeting.
Do you have any concerns or recommendations about new carpeting? How to impact someone with cancer?
Well, there's definitely toxic outgassing with all new carpet.
Carpet is obviously made with, you know, as a chemical and many carpets are sprayed with fire retardants.
I can't remember the name of the fire retardant, but that is a major neurotoxid in itself.
And so, yeah, you know, but you're going the route of a natural wool-based carpet to be extremely expensive and doesn't necessarily wear well.
And it's not very state-resisted at all. My son put in a, in their nursery, he put in a wool-based carpet that was expensive.
And it just, it did not. It was horrible, actually, as far as wear and, and state resistance goes. It was just, it was just, they just said it was just a big mistake.
So, you know, what do you do? Maybe wait till the summertime where you could open up all the windows and turn the fans on and try to, you know, get that stuff out of your house.
I can't remember who it was. Some movie star years ago had a video of hers.
Herder has been had a son, and he ended up with the severe neurotoxic disease diagnosis. They said he was.
And so, he was mentally retarded at the time with some strange neurotoxic disease. They ended up detoxing him going to, actually, a chiropractor out in California did detoxing.
The chiropractor did decadetiology, and I would found out that he was, he was, he was toxic with the fire, the fire retarded chemical, I believe, and some other chemicals did complete detoxing.
We don't know their house, the sun got better, and they wrote multiple articles about it and living, trying to have a clean house. So, I'll perfectly clean house.
Then would not include any carpeting and would all be hardwoods or tile and that's just not real practical. I mean, they'll use throw rugs. Well, the throw rugs have chemicals in them too.
It's, it's just difficult to balance that out. We certainly don't do that. We have walls wall carbonated areas of our house. We have some wood in areas of our house and obviously tile in the bathrooms, but yeah, it's, it's a difficult thing.
I mean, some people are going to have more issues with that. And it all depends upon different sensitivities. It depends on if they have damage to brain cells already and they have microglial priming. They're going to be more sensitive to those type of chemicals.
If they have compromised to the liver detox pathways, they're going to have a difficulty getting that stuff out. They're going to be more susceptible. Just like people are more susceptible to different toxins based upon, you know, the level of toxicity that they're dealing with right now.
And certainly if they're dealing with with cancer or some other, you know, more co-orbidity. So, yeah, you just have to find a balance. Maybe it's like, okay, well, we're just going to do it in the summertime and, you know, try to open the windows and leave the fans blowing and try to just maybe, maybe get the carpets cleaned even after we get them put in.
Anyways, when you get your carpets cleaned, you should clean with just hot water alone, never any soap or chemicals ever, ever, ever when you get carpets cleaned.
So, if you have any services now that do that or you do it yourself, rent a carpacleter or do it yourself, just with hot as water, as you can possibly get used to have a patient years ago that had a carpet cleaning service and he just cleaned carpets with boiling water.
And she's got great results, never used anything, but the stuff that he pulled out of carpets, the cleaning solution that was left behind from other cleaners was amazing.
So, maybe try that. That's another, you know, possible solution to get some of that stuff out.
A couple of years ago, I had a doctor, a friend of mine whose son is 12-year-old son or something was having major neurotoxic issues. I tested him, he tested positive for fire retarded chemicals.
And I said, I don't know what this is, it's fire retarded chemicals. Do you have any idea where he's getting that?
This was years ago before I knew anything about really fire retarded chemicals and he said, well, yeah, we just got a brand new pouch and he's been sleeping on the couch.
So, all he did is change where he's sleeping and all the symptoms went away plus he took some supplements to help detox it.
So, these things can be major issues. All the furniture you buy has that stuff in it. All baby clothes have that stuff in it. That's why my kids typically buy this natural, you know, organic cotton baby clothes, even though they're more expensive.
You don't want to put that garbage on your little baby.
So, yeah, it's just a matter of trying to strike a balance. Do you test everyone for glutathione or my genetic test show problems with my glutathione production?
Yes, I do test everyone for glutathione. So, if I didn't put your glutathione, you shouldn't be on glutathione.
My hematocrit is 33.9, range is 35 to 35. Why is this low and what can be done?
Well, there can be multiple reasons why your hematocrit can be low. You'd want to look at that along with your red blood cell coat.
And your other CBC values.
So, I want to look at your, look at the rest of your CBC.
So, yeah, you don't look at just one blood value alone. So you want to look at the rest of the CBC.
Should I have clarified, I should have clarified nicotine nicotine therapy talks about nicotine patches and possibly using organic nicotine SNUS to help with cancer management reduction your thoughts. Well, I'm not familiar with that.
So, I don't have an answer to that. I don't know. I've not ever used that. I've not even heard of that. So, I guess I don't have an answer for that. I apologize.
Something else to look into. So, red blood cells and hemoglobin are also on the lower side.
So, then that tells us that you are quite possibly anemic. So, hematocrit is measures the percentage of volume of red blood cells in a centrifuge contents of blood.
So, it's the part of the CBC that you look at the red blood cells, your hemoglobin, your red cell width and such.
And your mean corkoscular volume.
And your serabaritan and your total iron-biting capacity to help determine if you have anemia. So, if it's low, you could have iron deficiency anemia, you could have vitamin B12 anemia, you could have anemia due to blood loss.
And you could have anemia due to increased destruction, which is typically called anemia of chronic disease. So, anemia in cancer patients is typically from what's called anemia of chronic disease.
So, but I think you have been dealing with balancing on that anemia issue for a time and wasn't it you that increased your red meat consumption and that helped.
So, you need different nutrients to be able to make red blood cells, you need to be able to support the production of red blood cells.
But, whatever you have decreased red blood cells, decreased hemoglobin and other factors of anemia, you do want to look at do I have bleeding issues.
Maybe it's because I'm a woman and I have heavy periods. So, I'm losing blood that way. Am I making blood enough? Am I supporting blood production with my diet and my fasting too much.
And what else could cause anemia damage because I did radiation and doing chemotherapy.
Oxidizing agents can damage red blood cell production. So, those of you want to look at causes of it, make sure you investigate causes.
Many times with stage four cancer patients, the cause really is that the cancer is just basically gobbling up red blood cells and gobbling up.
I heard and hemoglobin for oxygen, that's oxygen carrying capacity of the blood and that's considered anemia of a chronic disease.
And you're always with cancer, you're always like, should I add iron supplementation because that could possibly feed cancer.
If I do that, I want to add artimistic it with it or should I just, you know, if I'm just kind of at that border, should I just, you know, add more, maybe red meat and beets and foods that could help build blood back.
And that is always what you want to do is your first step before you add iron supplementation.
You also want to look at ferritid. If your ferritid levels are high, then you don't want to add iron because then you know you have an inflammatory process.
Remember I said B12 anemia can cause anemia patterns as well.
So deficiency in B12 and remember your genetics also have defects on, you know, MTHFR defects, MTR and MTRR defects.
Those are genes on the folate pathway and the methydic pathway that can cause a deficiency in B12.
Because if one commonly overlooked issues and causes of anemia is a decrease in production of intrinsic factor, intrinsic factor is necessary for you to absorb B12.
So you might even be taking B12 but you're not absorbing it and you've got a B12 anemia because that why would you have a decrease in intrinsic factor.
The number one reason why you'd have a decrease in intrinsic factor is is hypochloridria.
So you have a decrease hydrochloric acid production in your stomach.
You need hydrochloric acid, you need an acidic stomach in order to make intrinsic factor, you need an acidic stomach in order to absorb iron and to absorb B12.
And remember I've talked about this zoom call and some videos about hydrochloric acid that is the number one issue worldwide is especially in America because of our poor America diet is damage the cells, the pride of cells and the stomach that made hydrochloric acid and the number one problem is a decrease hydrochloric acid.
So taking hydrochloric acid and concurrently digestive enzymes with each meal can be the fix for anemia.
So make sure that you're taking HCl with each meal and you're taking it enough, many times people aren't taking it enough.
So and with the size of the meal you should take more so that can be the fix for anemia.
Talk to people that don't have cancer that have suffered with anemia for decades and just fixing their stomach and hydrochloric acid production solves that problem.
And also people could have, you know, could suffer with symptoms from Hpylori for decades as well. So that's always caused from tied to hypochloridria. So look at that. I actually have a video on hypochloridria and Hpylori and everything on the blog post so make sure you look at those.
And I use chloroxygen, chlorophyll, the test comes good. I don't know what you mean by that. So you take this product and if you run a blood test and it's normal, I'm not quite sure.
Not sure, not sure, not pathway with that. If that was true, then why both you stay on that. If that's solving the endemia issue, might be affected Hpylori. Maybe that's why I'm not quite sure.
Okay, all right. Any other questions? All right. Well, we will say goodbye for today. Remember to get your questions in or do like you guys all did such a great job today.
Chatting those questions in. Thank you for another great day. We'll get this up. So anybody can listen to it if they missed. All right. God bless everybody. Bye bye.